In this project we've got
something a little bit silly.
We've got 100 classes,
each of which have 700 methods.
Well this is clearly
a contrived example.
In principle there is nothing stopping
a large project from getting this big
especially if you have
a lot of big dependencies.
So, let's try compiling this.
Oops, looks like we've got an error.
Trouble writing output.
Too many method references.
70,000, max is 65,000.
Let's unpack what's going on here.
The Android virtual machine doesn't
actually run Java byte code.
It runs Dalvik byte code.
And there's a build step
after java compilation,
where the Java byte code is
turned into Dalvik byte code.
The step is called dexing.
Part of this process is compiling
a table of every method
in the application,
which is then indexed with two bytes.
So, that means we're
limited to 65K methods.
Fortunately, we can ask gradleto simply
break up this table into multiple tables
by setting in our build.gradle
file under default config,
multiDexEnabled true.
Now if we try and build again, looking
through our build log we see that
the dex process was run successfully,
so now we're building just fine,
even though our project is gigantic.
This is just something to be aware of so
you don't get bit by this in the future.